[Music]
hello and it's a pleasure to welcome you
to how the light gets ins winter revel
my name is ron amita i teach the history
and politics modern china at oxford
university here in the uk where i'm
sitting at the moment in lockdown and
today i want to talk to you about a
concept which in a sense has become a
bit of a cliche but a cliche which i
think can be
unraveled with actually quite a lot of
useful purpose in understanding one of
the countries in the world which is
making the most waves but sometimes
provokes the least level of
understanding and that is of course
china china the country that is in the
minds of pretty much every person in
every western capital these days
washington dc london berlin wherever it
might be
and whose behavior and his actions
sometimes seem to be in some ways very
hard to understand so getting to the
heart of what really makes up china's
dna is my task in the next half hour or
so i'm going to take you through some
ideas about that let's start though
with this gentleman here probably
familiar to you from the news i hope so
anyway xi jinping general secretary of
the communist party of china president
of the people's republic of china and a
whole variety of other very grand
positions in addition to that now xi
jinping has regularly been in the news
when he turns up at some of the premier
spots
where the west talks to itself and davos
the world economic forum inevitably is
going to be one of those places and i've
got two pictures here
the lower one is of uh xi jinping
speaking in 2017 at davos and uh the one
at the top is actually him speaking at
virtual devils because of course it was
online this year because of the pandemic
both of these talks by xi jinping had
some similarities and both of them had
some differences essentially the one in
2017 is worth remembering because it was
given in the month that donald j trump
was inaugurated as president of the
united states and the second one was
given in the month that donald j trump
left the presidency of the united states
to make way for joe biden
and
in both of these talks the message from
xi jinping about china in the world was
quite similar he talked about china as
being the country that really was
underpinning international order the
country which really people had to pay
attention to if they wanted to support
free and fair trade uh the upholding of
uh broader human values a whole variety
of very warm sounding very positive
sounding elements which i think in both
cases were being formulated by him
without him ever saying so to try and
provide a point of contrast with the
united states
and that contrast perhaps was stronger
in the era of donald trump a president
who decided that he was going to
diverge from the international order
that had become so much part of the
world we've lived in since 1945
and perhaps perhaps not seems less
divergent in the era of a perhaps more
conventional president
but to understand what it was that xi
jinping was trying to say i think during
those talks we have to understand a bit
more about where he
and the chinese communist party and why
the chinese society have been coming
from
for years and decades in some cases even
centuries
now the expression that something is in
someone's dna you know freedom is in
america's dna you know order is in
china's dna whatever just as i said a
bit of a cliche i mean dna you know is
not the right way to think about big
large complex societies in a very
detailed sort of granular way but i
think this idea of something that's
fundamental to them can be useful and
this particular case the reason that i
think that this dna model is a useful
way to think about it is because of what
those elements are
and i'm going to argue during the course
of the next 20 minutes or so that if we
understand four particular factors
authoritarianism
consumerism
globalization
and technology these four
then those
four factors and the way they recombine
with each other tells us something quite
fundamental about why modern china why
contemporary china is the way it is and
the way it's going to be for quite some
time to come and why it's so different
from so many other societies around the
world and those of you who are
biologists or even if you're not
biologists may support it there's
another reason why the dna
metaphor analogy appealed to me so much
those initials a c
g t that you see on screen right now
they are of course also the initials of
the names of the nucleotides the four
different chemicals that make up a
strand of dna so
although the the order acgt is slightly
different in in dna the initials are the
uh the same that's another reason that i
thought this is quite a useful mnemonic
in terms of understanding what the
elements are because
like dna if you take those acgt
nucleotides and put them together dna
makes up so much more than the sum of
its parts it's a very long distance from
looking under an electron microscope a
little speck of dna and seeing a human
being even though of course one is made
up of the other and in the case of china
these four factors are a starting point
but they're not enough
the combination the recombination and
the making of more than some of the
parts is why china is i think so
distinctive
well to understand that i think we need
to think a bit more about the sources of
chinese conduct i use the word conduct
there to echo the essay back in 1947 i
think it was by george kennan the great
american geopolitical thinker about what
he called the sources of soviet conduct
since those days it was the soviet union
not china that was the major
geopolitical opposites to the western
world
and thinking about china today
i think that the chinese communist party
the party state that runs china draws
its legitimacy from a whole variety of
sources the one it doesn't draw from of
course is democratic legitimacy because
china neither has a liberal democratic
system based on elections nor does it
make any pretense certainly these days
of wanting to do so so where does it
draw its sense of strength and
legitimacy from well i say there are
several factors number one is its modern
history the story that china tells about
itself to its own people and that it
tells in the wider world is a story of
repeated invasion and defense against
outside occupation and attack
that starts in the mid 19th century with
the opium wars where the british of
course turn up with gun boats off the
south coast of china
wanting to break open the doors of
china's closed economy as they saw it
selling opium and also bringing along
with them bibles missionaries western
modes of thinking and modernity in
general
and for many chinese certainly at the
time and even now
the century that followed was a very
unhappy one from the 1830s through the
1940s
then and even now sometimes called the
century of humiliation for china as i
say a very unhappy period and this
includes factors or events such as the
occupation of hong kong at the end of
the opium war uh the seeding of parts of
manchuria and northeast china uh in the
1890s and 1900s and eventually of course
the occupation of manchuria by the
japanese in the 1930s
ultimately leading to the outbreak of
full-scale world war ii in asia 1937 is
when that starts in china and the war
goes on for eight years till 1945 when
china finally ends up on the allied side
of the war exhausted but ultimately
victorious
so that whole history of attack
oppression and defense against the
outside is one factor that explains the
highly defensive language that you hear
so often when china chooses to define
itself to the outside world my own take
is that much of this i think is deeply
exaggerated these days china today is a
strong country whereas 100 years ago it
was very much a weak country but that
having been said you can understand
historically one of the reasons why that
sense of oppression from outside remains
a very powerful factor
the second factor is the one that you
tend to come up with most when you deal
with china's place in the world as an
economic business actor which is the
idea that whatever you think of it
china's economic reform certainly since
the late 1970s early 1980s
have provided the source for a huge
increase in uh poverty reduction or
enrichment if you want to put it in a
more positive way in china itself over
the last 40 years
regardless of the methods and the
methods could often be quite brutal and
quite painful you can look at the
statistics and see that from being an
immensely impoverished country in the
1970s china has moved to being as i'm
sure you're aware the second biggest
economy in the world in the 2010s 2020s
that shift did not come from nowhere
so that ability of the chinese system
authoritarian and dictatorial though it
is to provide economic growth and wealth
is a very important pillar of legitimacy
the third one again it's one that's
sometimes unappreciated under
appreciated i think is the uh
dependence on what you might call
traditional thought particularly
thinking of
great chinese philosophers of the past
like confucius
who had a whole variety of ideas that we
still find very congenial today the idea
of a harmonious world being one of them
and other ideas that frankly are
probably not so congenial if you look
into many detail confusions and
traditional confusion thinking was not
about equality but about hierarchy and
in the modern world we don't tend to
think very much about hierarchy as
something that societies might actually
want rather than trying to overcome but
in the case of traditional confusion
thinking
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas